what is this thing you just sent me oh
it's really cool it's a picture of the
most relaxing Meadow you've ever seen
idiot I know what this is It's supposed
to lull me into a sense of calm and then
a ghoul pops up and scares me why would
I do that Dwight of all people I know
that you're unscurable damn right I am
oh hello relaxing Meadow I'm so relaxed
and calm looking at you right now
oh no scary goal just popped up I'm so
scared I'm so scared really is this the
best you could
Jim how are you okay
um
that is the best I can do
no
no no no no no no no no no no
oh my God
I do not want to talk about it
unbelievable that
okay what happened Michael oh wouldn't
you like to know what happened in the
bathroom by myself pervy suffice to say
I finished my business I was just
checking to make sure everything was
fine and my cell phone fell out and on
not in but like on the rim and then it's
not just let me tell the story okay Jim
I knocked her with my knee and then it
fell in and then I leaned over and
looked and my Bluetooth fell out of my
ear and that fell in Bluetooth and then
I got flustered and everything started
falling in my wallet fell in my tip
calculator my candy corn my white strips
all fell in to the toilet and you're
Keys felon I threw the keys in out of
anger this cannot happen again that's
what you said last time I know I did
Phyllis isn't
enough well technically it is toilet
humor which you claim to enjoy it is not
toilet humor it is toilet tragedy
hey
hey you know what
this is the best thing that ever
happened to me
and don't doubt it
ladies and gentlemen a while ago you
witnessed a tragedy that befell me in
the bathroom but As the adage goes out
of great tragedy
is the mother of invention so without
further Ado I would like to present to
you something that I believe will change
the way that we all do business
so to speak behold
the mesh toilet guard
handy portable self-cleaning
this little baby goes where you go
who wants to give it a test spin Phyllis
Stanley
Kev Moana
who wants to take it on its maiden
voyage anyone
come on
here's an idea how to handle that puppy
and you got yourself a tennis racket
I totally not prefer to do it okay well
all right I have a little something
I could do
excuse me
does it need to be clean oh wait a
second
oh
[Music]
wow I know what Kelly is doing
she's trying to butter Michael up
oh where'd it go oh my God Michael you
are so much fun when people start
sucking up to you it is very easy to get
an inflated ego you start to believe all
though hype people are saying about you
and I am not yet at that point but I'm
going to get there
yeah we have that going on Tuesday
okay
sure no I can I'll double check that for
you
I would like to tell you a little story
let me call you right back okay about a
boy named
it that doesn't even matter could be any
one of you
and like any other 12 year old boy he
wanted a Pippy long stocking doll for
Christmas
but his evil stepfather Jeff said no you
may not have what you want you must have
a football
and the boy cried and he cried and he
cried and he held his breath as long as
he could and he wouldn't eat his dinner
but you know something
it turns out
that Jeff was right because I already
had a GI Joe and a Stretch Armstrong and
a Malibu Barbie and a major Matt Mason
which technically is enough for a tea
party so my point is this I didn't need
what I thought I needed what I needed
was to learn how to appreciate what I
had which in this case was enough dolls
to have tea with exactly
foreign
[Music]
this is Ryan
oh hi David
long time no talk
through the temp agency actually
yeah
I got that
I I know that
David
you don't have to yell
David can can I just
let me just tell
him
okay
I don't okay
right
please hold
he just made the list
hey Toby I have a real quick question
for you
sure
what should your resume be and what
should you do with your life okay
two questions I guess fine no no no I'm
sticking to what I said
one question with two parts okay well
look the second part you know that's
really personal I mean only you can
answer that so you're trying to get out
of it God
thanks for your help [ __ ]
okay well look the resumes I can really
help you there I must read 20 a day okay
good
write this down
born in a medium-sized Town Michael Gary
Scott always knew he was different so we
might start with say your most recent
thing summary of achievements what have
you done here at Thunder Mifflin change
things ushered in a new era
of love and comedy in the workplace
hired many fired few made money lost
money
learned to stop counting
This is Our Moment
this is our time
this next part should be sung if
possible
what is this what happened here
I don't know
oh this does not look good did anyone
see what happened around my desk area
this morning what I really think
someone's probably just playing a prank
on you so just go right through it
this is official police line tape okay
not a prank probably yes nothing much is
happening today
we are having a photo IDs taken
whoop-dee-doo
can't always be like The Apprentice
I know
on Big Brother
something important happens every day
real life is not like that damn it
people someone must have seen something
how you people are useless
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
hold please
Dwight it's the sheriff he said that
it's really important it's regarding
your desk I'll transfer oh no no
I can't hit
um
just cut through it this is why I am a
volunteer sheriff's deputy and you are
not that is not why
wow man he really wants to get in touch
with you maybe it's a murder no there's
no blood maybe poison possibly my God
[Music]
Sheriff this is volunteer sheriff's
deputy Dwight Schrute press the pound
key
what's your 20.